[Music]
what is going on reject nation
we are two men with big foreheads and
ponytails
and we are going to watch today from
chris
over at the channel cosmic culture
shazam
two first look at new super suit
and leaked set footage
let's get that shazam train rolling in
on board
let's go
[Music]
hey everybody how's it going welcome
back to cosmic culture the channel where
we talk about all major movie and
television news theories breakdowns and
much much more
i'm chris and today we have our first
look at shazam 2
fury of the gods it's an unofficial look
coming to us from reddit user
cello owned who posted a footage from
the production
of shazam 2 and gives us a cooler look
into the movie
as of right now there is so relatively
little out there about
what shazam two is going to be covering
who's going to be involved
the villains and if we're going to be
getting other cameos from characters
inside the dc eu or the dc universe but
after following the first shazam movie
which honestly
i think fans received pretty well i for
one definitely enjoyed it i thought it
was a cool premise
and it definitely leaves a lot of cool
connecting points in the future
for any possible team-up movies you know
black adams coming out and that
hopefully will fit into
the next shazam movie or possibly even
in some aspect
this one and we're going to have to wait
to see all that but for now
check out this footage from the set
okay so they're back in philadelphia all
right
some sure like with all footage that
comes from sets filmed on phones or
from far far away you don't actually get
a whole lot from it but it is exciting
to see
one production is moving the movies
should come out on schedule
all of those good things what is that
the last year and a half two years we
haven't really had that promise
everything's been pushed back delayed
halted but
we're back on schedule movies are
releasing regularly people are going to
the theaters
and the movie industry is back so she's
answering that
on target for its release there
shouldn't be any issue there
number two is there is a slight
appearance that shazam's costume is
going to be a little bit different
and we do have photos of that that i'll
show here briefly that do demonstrate a
new suit is in the worst
now the first shazam outfit from the
first movie definitely that is
tight fitting vibe to it with its beauty
look at that crotch
soft fabric but this one has a little
bit more of a modern dc hero feel to it
it's very tight it almost has a carbon
fiber
look not as cartoony and definitely fits
the modern dc vibe
and although we haven't gotten a first
look at black adam's
full character outfit it makes me wonder
if maybe they changed it to match that a
little bit more
rock isn't going to want to wear
something that matches what shazam was
wearing
but we do know these characters are
going to meet down the line so they have
to look
somewhat like they're meant to be
together and that could be a possibility
for the change or also just because they
wanted to leave that cartoon
feel for the outfit that they're wearing
and go into something a little bit more
super that was the rockstar see in this
video that shazam is up on top of
something dropping down potentially
flying and dropping onto the roof but we
also see exiting the vehicle
all of the kids who are meeting him
there and he is in shazam
form so yeah they got him on like a chip
where we left off where all the kids are
now part of that
family and their heroes in their own
essence and in their own way and there's
going to be an involvement in that
fighting the big bad or fixing whatever
issue there is
that is going to show up as far as i'm
aware black adam is not going to connect
to shazam to fury of the gods
just yet we're going to have to wait to
get black adam in with shazam either for
the second black adam movie or the third
shazam movie
where there will be a connecting and
they're going to fill
that blank little cliffhanger from the
end where there was an
empty throne that we all know belongs to
black adam
but the new suit looks really good and
i'm excited for this second film just
seeing this little clip got me
thinking about how much i enjoyed the
first one and how much i can't wait for
the future of this part of the franchise
dc is undergoing a huge
change right now waiting for the flash
movie to come out the flashpoint movie
that's going to open up the dc eu
and connect the infinite parallel
universes as jim lee has
explained to us but for now we do have a
decent franchise set up with shazam
a good storyline that isn't too too
confusing like dc likes to do to us with
all
over the place plot lines but just a
simple
shazamly movie it's probably a simple
sequel i wouldn't expect too many
crossovers or connecting points
just yet but after the flash movie comes
out and a little bit more is made clear
to us sure then maybe shazam can make
his way over to fight with or against
other heroes and villains
and of course the long-awaited
connection to black adam
but a very exciting little clip to see
new suit
storyline kind of there somewhere we see
the kids are still involved which is
awesome
but be sure to subscribe to the channel
and turn on that notification bell and
i'll tell you why we're posting daily
uploads
for dc marvel star wars and all major
movie and television news you can also
check us out on other socials tik tok
twitter and discord where the community
is talking
daily about what they're most excited
for in the realm of major
movie and television news thank you guys
so much for watching to the very end of
the video and i'll see in the next one
right here
on cosmic culture well then i know
lately our style has been more like
pause talk and then continue the
reaction
pause you know talk continue the
reaction and when we let it play the
whole way through subscribe to cosmic
culture but i am taking the look of the
new suit
it's a lot more firm fitting and you're
right like the the other one
from before was a lot like bulkier
looked more like in a cartoony
children's fashion whereas
this new one feels like that's a badass
suit right there like it really brings
out the muscles it looks like zachary
levi's actual
build versus the other one which was
like is real
that does not look like it's real it has
like a plushy almost halloween costume
not that it looked
bad in the previous movie but you know
much more appropriate of a whimsical
take on a character whereas this looks
like he is and even
looking at zachary levi's face he looks
a bit more grown up a bit more
of a man well his hair is even more uh
yeah trimmed down a little bit closer he
looks a little more leaned
out with any good superhero what is his
tv show with another season
or a movie they usually do updates on
refining
the suit and to me this is like such a
noticeable
change the thing is a lot of times with
like these leaked set photos with the
suits it can
be like oh man that does not look good
because of the except for that you see
it when it's actually been color
corrected and
complemented by how they're capturing
with the cinematography then you're like
oh never mind
it looks fine here this is set photos
and you're like damn that looks really
good
photos yeah the only thing i'm sitting
here wondering is are they gonna cg that
cape on probably
you know and yeah but it looks pretty
complete from here it
seems like because he's with the cape he
has right here in this photo
wherever the cape latches onto that
helps the cape stay on
so it has to be a cgi cape which is what
they usually do nowadays for a lot of
these comic book movies
yeah it's way more manageable yeah got a
lot more
mobility and i'm excited for it i'm glad
people are getting excited for furry of
the gods guys
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that notification bell hit that
like button last but not least
andrew hayes you're the first person who
came to my mind when
seeing this news this video i think is
shazam like who's the perfect patron to
call out
it'd probably be andrew hayes because
andrew you're a sweet guy i've been
seeing your instagram posts lately
looking
sexy with the long hair but also i would
imagine you being a type of superhero
character who's got some magic word
then transforms him into a huge buff
muscular dude capable of leaping tall
buildings in a single bound
and unlocking any luck because of your
family business
anyway though i hope you're doing well i
miss our chat like i've been thinking
back on like some of the old times of
patreon now that we've gotten as far as
we have in like those old days
on the google hangouts with you man i
miss that so i hope that before 2021
ends we can all chat in some way that
isn't just
through one of these shout outs man all
as a team as a group
as a family of orphans
who aren't actually orphans
thank you andrew